- Our first on today's
Twitter questionnaire
comes from David Covucci, I think?
"Everyone is talking about
good quarantine habits,
tell me your worst.
I for one have started chewing
nicotine gum for no reason,
other than it was on
sale at the pharmacy."
What?
(laughing)
I want your life David,
'cause obviously not a lot is
going on, and I'm very busy.
I don't, what's your worst
quarantine habit, Seth?
- I dunno, I think I'm
over-flossing, just to like,
break up the day.
(laughing)
- Oh my!
You know what I'm doing?
Q-tips.
I already am a Q-tip queen,
I love cleaning my ears,
I can't stand, I can't stand like,
any kind of moisture in my ears.
And I've been showering a lot,
'cause we live on a ranch.
And I'm probably going
to ruin my ears, somehow.
- Look, I love a good Q-tip
but I like to savor it.
When I feel like over-using a Q-tip,
takes away the excitement.
For me it's a treat.
(laughing)
It's like very...
You know, if I accomplish something,
then I'm like, "You
grab yourself a Q-tip."
- Yeah.
I love cleaning out my ears, okay.
- Can I ask you a Q-tip question?
- Yes.
- Do you one Q-tip that
you switch for each ear?
Or does each ear get one Q-tip?
- Here's the weird thing about me,
it's so interesting you asked.
I do one Q-tip, and I do one side,
and then I do the other side deep-in.
And then I take another
Q-tip and I do like, around,
you know, inside the ear.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then I do the same
thing with the other side.
- Wow.
- Yeah, it's a process.
- Yeah.
- I enjoy Q-tips, I call them,
"Ear-gasms", they're good.
- There you go.
- We may wanna not put that in the show.
(laughing)
or, I don't know, hell, put it in!
All right, the next one
is from @HelloCullen.
"What if Seinfeld met the Sopranos?"
(laughing)
That is actually a great question!
- Just like, what, what happened?
- [Kelly] Yeah, like, what,
so Seth, what do you think?
Turf war?
Like I'm just saying--
- I dunno.
I think like, Jerry would
be like, "what's the deal
with Pauly Walnuts?"
(laughing)
- Why?
- "Why is the side of his hair white?"
- I think it would be more
interesting to see Kramer
with them.
Anyway, I love Seinfeld--
- Kramer would definitely
like, sort of like,
blow up the Mafia somehow.
- Yes, it would have been a great episode.
Good question!
Okay, this next one is from J Portnay,
who asks, "What is the dumbest fight
you've gotten into in quarantine?"
Well, you know what, here's the thing.
You should never ask
a married person that.
(laughing)
- Because there's plenty.
- Right, yeah.
- I don't even know, like
Bran and I, it's just 'cause
the kids are crazy, everything's crazy,
and all the world together,
I mean, you and your wife,
have you all just been--
- Yeah.
- Stupid things.
- Well I'd have to say,
well our two year old like,
he played, fell and hit
his chin and you know,
he split it open and I
immediately panicked,
'cause I thought we were gonna have to go
the emergency room,
which is obviously not a
place you wanna be right now.
You know, because you don't wanna require
the attention of first responders,
who are dealing with
more important things.
And basically while I was flipping out
and screaming about how bad it was,
my wife just like, put a
Band-Aid on it and fixed it.
(laughing)
Making it very clear,
that I'm not the person
you want in a crisis.
(laughing)
- Okay, I'm you, and my husband is her.
I would have been like, "Oh my God!"
I can't even, there's not even,
we've had so many dumb
arguments, like stupid.
And then we, and then literally
in a moment we're like,
"This is so stupid, like,
let's just go have a drink."